good morning believe nation my name is
Lily MA and my one word is extraordinary
I believe that every single human being
is capable of extraordinary things so to
help you on your journey to these
messages create your own luck over to
you Donald Trump what would be one word
of advice you would have for an upcoming
businessman
knowledge knowledge but if it's one word
one words very hard for that but the
word is knowledge but you get knowledge
through experience one of the things
people talk about is luck and I do
believe that people are lucky and some
people are luckier than others I do
believe that but there's also an
expression the harder you work the
luckier you get and I can tell you ten
instances where I didn't quit one it was
1990 the world was coming down the debt
markets were - everybody all of my
friends and enemies were going bankrupt
I never did and the but try I mean the
times were actually just terrible and
even today you look at times and you see
what happens and you have to learn but
the word luck is very interesting but if
I didn't work really hard I probably
would not almost definitely would not be
here today and unless you had me up as a
man who at one point was successful but
let's see what a loser looks like so you
have to work hard because it is true you
can develop luck through hard work so I
think luck plays a part in people's
success but a really small part it
becomes a problem
if that's all you focus on it becomes a
problem when you use it as an excuse not
to go out there and do something with
your life it becomes an even bigger
problem if you're always waiting for a
luck to come your way so for example I'm
just starting out as a speaker I'm in my
early stages of my speaking career I
look at Evan he just went to Paris
and he spoke in front of thousands of
people ate at a fancy restaurant sat at
first-class airlines went to a beautiful
hotel and he was given this opportunity
and he is so lucky right that is not the
mindset that I need to have that kind of
mindset will completely destroy my
future and will not help me grow the
reason why Evan had that opportunity is
through years and years of dedicated
hard work over time I work with that man
I know how consistent he is I know how
determined he is and I know how
dedicated he is to his mission and the
reason why I don't have that luck or
that opportunity is because I don't
deserve it yet and it's no way of me to
knock myself down at all instead it
raises me even higher because I am not
waiting for some elusive fairy to come
around and sprinkle dust over my head
that is called luck for this to happen
it is within my control I have the
responsibility and accountability to
make that happen for myself I need to
work harder I need to work harder
consistently over time keep working keep
working be dedicated to my mission keep
working gain knowledge through research
and soon enough that opportunity will
come my way so next time you look at
someone that you that you think has a
lot of luck in their life change your
mindset around and find ways to create
your own luck so the question of the day
is what is that one opportunity you
really want in your life that hasn't
happened for you yet and hopefully when
you write it down it's gonna give me
that fuel the fire to go and make your
own luck so leave in the comments below
and I will join in on the discussion so
I also have a quick chatter for Evan Lee
Anto thank you so much for picking up a
copy of Evans book your one word your
support means a lot to us and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you so
much for watching I believe in you and I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is
and we'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
I think I think that's one of the
strongest things you can cultivate as an
entrepreneur is to not rely on luck but
cultivating and the ability to recognize
fortunate situations when they're
occurring mm-hmm
odyo was a very fortunate situation
could have taken that idea not told it
to have not told it to be is not not
told it to know and and all my other
co-workers at OU do and tried to start
my own company with with that idea but
the fortunate situation was I was
working with some really amazing people
and we had a great team so of course you
know it makes sense to start there
the fortunate situation for square was
that in 2008 at the end of 2008 the
entire market was crashing down like all
of these abstractions we built upon
abstraction upon abstraction upon
abstraction in the financial world which
no single human understood we're now
falling apart and suddenly we're getting
back to basics back to fundamentals
management teams were being asked to
leave banks were failing you know people
were we're clarifying around like we
need to start getting innovative if we
need to start treating our customers so
poorly we need to start insight we need
to stop you know encouraging bad
behavior to reap fees like we need to
really turn this whole thing around and
anytime there's a recession or a
depression that's a great time to
innovate start a company start a project
you know do anything so you know we
recognize we recognize that time in the
same time my co-founder Jim we you know
we contacted me he I've known him since
I was 15 years old he was my boss when I
was 15 years old and he's like Jack I
want to talk to you I want to I want to
build an electronic car company like
that's interesting and he was thinking
about it because the car industry was
failing as well and like he was like why
don't we just give these car companies
to well seasoned entrepreneurs like why
don't we give Ford to Steve Jobs and
like you know that would be amazing
yeah it would be amazing and like you
know GM to Ellison are like
he's like and also I want to start an
electronic car company I'm like you know
that that's ambitious but in that moment
we decided not to start an electronic
car company but we wanted to do
something together mm-hm and we kept
having these weekly conversations about
what that thing was and I was
researching a lot with finance and
healthcare because I was looking at you
know doing something in those spaces and
and Jim called me one day one of us
scheduled me to meetings and he said I
just lost a glass sale he's an artist he
he sells class and I lost the sale
because I couldn't accept a credit card
and here he was talking on his iPhone
his general-purpose computer and I was
talking about my iPhone I'm like well
you're Hertz computer sitting in the
palm of your hand but no way to accept
credit he couldn't accept two thousand
dollars from from someone who wanted to
pay him right like why is that so we
decided that we wanted to answer that
question and we did a bunch of research
and I started writing some server code
and we hired a guy to write some iPhone
code and Jim built some hardware and in
a month we had a little right it was
actually quite a big device that plugged
into the audio jack of your iPhone and
could swipe a card take a payment it
would go through the merchant process
and then generate a receipt with a map
on it and I went around I showed it to a
bunch of investors and they were all
amazed that it could even work so we
decided to really focus on it and make
it a make it a company and and it really
just comes down to like recognizing that
fortunate situation and recognizing the
people around you that that could help
him and just owning you were bold you
kind of talked him up you ended up
selling him a help selling his house but
you approached him and you said are you
ready to sell one of your houses you
already knew that he owned two houses
you knew where they were you know so
isn't that also a big part of this you
have to really do the hard work yeah and
and really preparing yourself to be
lucky putting yourself in situations
where where you can get lucky where it's
not so much luck it's preparation I tell
a story about how I'm staying inside a
line in Starbucks and I'm not at that
Starbucks because I like coffee I'm at
that Starbucks because that's where all
the wealthy people and all the
celebrities in Beverly Hills go every
morning I
meet a guy in line in front of me I end
up showing him a house later that
afternoon and he buys a twelve million
dollar house some people would say
that's luck for me it's all about being
in the right place and there was a
reason why I'm there because I'm an
expert in my community and I put myself
in that situation